deep in an underwater cave on Mexico's
Yucatan Peninsula
a team of archaeologists make a
groundbreaking discovery the skulls of
ancient Maya ruled over 4,000 year old
civilization and perhaps most surprising
was that these skulls had grilles the
ancient history of grilles is a
little-known story which modern-day fans
are mostly unaware when grilled in your
mouth you get a sense of power of
dignity what people don't know is that
grilles had an unexpected history one
that goes back literally thousands of
years these grilles they want to
demonstrate status is like saying I'm
successful in life that I can just solve
in my teeth now I have money so look at
my teeth doesn't sound so different than
what's real stand for today so why do
they get such mixed reactions when
grilles first emerged in the US in the
early 80s it was through immigrants from
the African Diaspora who were going
through tough economic times ironically
gold is one of the cheapest ways to fill
a cavity so many black neighborhoods in
Brooklyn and the Bronx suddenly had all
these people with gold teeth native New
Yorker started to get gold teeth as a
fashion statement in the rise of hip hop
in the 80s led to a reclaiming of what
they could represent turning a sign of
poverty into proof of empowerment grills
fun but mainstream around 1996 when
Vietnamese immigrant Johnny gang began
making his own blinged out version of
them my name is Johnny dang they call me
the king of bling aka the grill master
I would say that a lot of people out
there they have a misconception of grill
it's been a big part of our culture okay
so I remember being very small and
seeing my grandma flow with a gold cap
right here and my auntie Mona the gold
cap right here educated
I have no felony criminal history just
because somebody chooses to show them by
putting it in their mouth makes them no
different from the person that has eight
cars it wasn't cheap but you've got to
be a hard worker to get something like
this
you know I'm fan yeah not cleaning your
grill can cause bad read the Mason still
brush teeth two to three times a day
keep it polished keep a sign in the
canal
[Music]